there's nothing in the platform I
particularly disagree with what I
disagree with and I'm appalled by is our
lack of fiscal restraint our
out-of-control spending we betrayed the
fundamental principles the Republican
Party which is restraint of spending and
restraint in the growth of government we
preside over the greatest increase in
the size of government since the Great
Society and we let spending get
completely out of control and our base
became dis dispirited and disenchanted
and we now have such a corrupt system
that former members of Congress are
residing in federal prison so that's
frankly and I a little Straight Talk the
present long ago six years ago should
have started vetoing these big spending
bills and he didn't and so we got the
bridge to nowhere haven't examined their
platform but I always admired the belief
and commitment of the Democrat Party to
freedom and democracy all over the world
Henry scoop Jackson who was a leading
Democrat was one of my heroes on that
Harry Truman was a man of incredible
courage and foresight which he's now
only getting credit for I respect the
Democrat parties many of them advocacy
of human rights and for democracy in
many parts of the world and I think
there's a degree of compassion and
caring in the Democratic Party that I
admire I don't admire their big
government solutions but I certainly
admire their concern and care
all
you